Have you reached Scalar Energy for Healy?
There are many companies making equipment that you think is good.
Spooky2 makes Scalar Wave Generator that includes a mode for
RIFE of F to run concurrent with the Scalar.
So Scalar Energy is kind of an alternative term.
So it really means you're using light frequencies is what Scalar Energy means.
Now there's different companies and different people to talk about Scalar Energy
in a different way. They're defining that term a little bit differently.
But I don't use the term Scalar Energy because it isn't a scientific
physics term. So it's that's why I don't use that term.
But it is a selling point in different RIFE circles. We have to use Scalar Energy.
Well what is Scalar Energy? So you want to use light frequencies, that's my opinion.
So again, different modes of healing, like a pulsed electromagnetic field therapy, a PEMF.
That's only using electrical frequencies. It's not using light frequencies.
And it's in a very specific range, a PEMF unit. Most PEMF units can't even change the frequency range.
So hopefully that helped answer your question. You want to use light frequency to help kill pathogens
and kill cancer cells. Electrical frequency isn't really going to do that at all. So Scalar Energy
is another term for light frequencies. And other companies may use that term differently because it's not
maybe adequately defined because it isn't a scientific term in itself. Hopefully that helps.